Pam is with us in Sacramento hi Pam how
are you hi Dave
thanks for taking my call I look up on
my screen looks like you got the same
stuff going on what's up
I do but just a little bit different in
the sense that you know we've known
about you for a few years and you know
we've definitely talked about trying to
walk through the plans but there's never
any action taken and you know I've just
kind of gotten to a point where I've
learned to just leave my husband alone
and not really bother him too much but I
but you know I still push forward I turn
things off we all have cable we try to
you know pack lunch when we can I
homeschool the children in the day so
that we don't have to pay for childcare
but then I work at night until two
o'clock in the morning just to make all
these things happen and it's just really
stressful because we can have schedules
like that there isn't a whole lot of
time for communication and you better
like you better make some because
there's going to be some communication
that isn't going to be pretty you're
going to blow up I'm blowing up and
they're just getting bad and I'm excited
because we're going to see you on March
1st oh good yeah so I'm excited about
that but the reason why I finally called
in today which I'm really glad to have
done with today is you know we're now in
a situation where it's like my mother is
really pressing us to buy a house well
my mother's jump in the creek well she's
offering us $100,000 watching my house
for a hundred thousand fine but right
now you got a bunch of other crap going
on this is like this is like just like a
young couple goes hey we're a marriage
trouble let's have a baby it'll make it
better right that's about how dumb that
is okay and that's how I feel I feel
like this is really about those well no
matter why don't we do this why don't we
say to mom why don't we say to husband
honey we're about to hit the wall here
let's spend six months not hitting the
wall and at the end of that six months
we'll talk to mom again and say mom I
really want to do this but we need to
get on the same page and we need a six
month track record before we can do
that or yeah 100,000 is a nice gift I'd
like to receive it but I want to receive
it into a healthy functioning household
not one where the wife is calling me on
a national radio show in the verge of
tears
right hey you follow me oh yeah
and just say mom either this is an
incredible gift but uh hubby and I
talked about it and we're not on the
same page we got to get our money stuff
going and we're going to work really
hard for six months on our money stuff
and then then the gift will be a
blessing right now I'm afraid it would
be a curse can you wait six months and
she's going to go ma-maa well whatever
back off surely you should understand
okay good if you give her if you give
her a real reason and there's a we're
heading somewhere with this then that's
what I would do that'll work don't work
that's what I do
hey good question hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]